Chism's Boyd turn superdude billy batson
is a much-needed volt of bright cheerful
lightning for the normally dark and
brooding DCE you in addition to being a
great movie the film was also filled
with nerdy Easter eggs for longtime
comic book fans here are some of the
small details we noticed in Shazam
spoilers ahead
whoa Shazam may be synonymous with DC
Comics today the big red cheese was
originally published by Fawcett comics
beginning in 1939 back then he was known
as Captain Marvel no it's not it's not
my name that's the whole other story
his 1939 birthday makes him just
slightly younger than Superman but those
few months would have a huge impact in
1941 DC launched a campaign against
Fawcett to get them to stop publishing
Captain Marvel alleging that he was just
a copy of Superman drawing the prolonged
legal battle which lasted until 1953 DC
even creatively borrowed some story
aspects from Captain Marvel including
his power to fly rather than just leap
tall buildings and his bald-headed
arch-nemesis the court decided in favor
of DC an outcome that crippled fossa
later in 1972 DC bought the rights to a
number of Fawcett characters that they
were no longer allowed to use including
Captain Marvel but there seems to be no
lingering hate between DC and what was
once for sick comics as these he drops a
pretty bold tribute to Shazam's true
origins plastered across the lunchroom
wall is a name of Billy's alma mater
Fawcett central that wasn't the last
name drop that the movie had in store
though when Billy's foster family finds
the real names of Billy's parents his
father is simply identified as CC Batson
a very clear reference to Shazam's
original co-creator CC Beck
Shazam fans probably recognized mr. mind
imprisoned in a glass dome as Savannah
enter the rock of eternity even before
the film's mid-credits scene gave the
little worm a full reveal if a character
is called mr. mind and he's a squirmy
little worm with a very weird backstory
he's from outer space he's Friends of
Nazis and runs a monster society
sometimes it can even eat dimensions
after Savannah returns to the rock of
eternity as an adult and defeats the
wizard Shazam he
only less the seven deadly enemies of
man escape that mr. mind also breaks out
setting up the weirdest mid-credits
scene of all time
young Billy Batson is separated from his
teenage mother after she fails to win
him a stuffed tiger at a carnival
later on Shazam hands a tiger doll to a
terrified young girl to calm her there
are Tigers on Shazam's costume so what's
up with all these Tigers as always
there's a reason rooted in comics one of
Billy's best friends is a talking tiger
obviously that tiger mr. talkie Tony
first appeared in 1947 Captain Marvel
Adventures issues 79 where it was
revealed that he's just an ordinary
tiger who really really wanted to wear
clothes and eat ice cream after
consuming a brain energizing serum why
does he need his fancy brain potion to
defend himself against a murder he'd
been accused of of course it's all weird
Tony hops on a boat and shows up in the
city where everyone is terrified of free
roaming Tigers even when they politely
ask questions all this resolved however
when Captain Marvel secures Tony a job
as a museum guide Paul's well that ends
well and Tony has given a place among
the Marvel family if we already have
talking worms talking Tigers can't be
that far behind
and speaking of talking animals
somewhere on the rock of eternity
there's a giant cavern full of doors two
different worlds one door in particular
opens up to crocodiles playing poker and
they aren't just an invention for the
movie the crocodile men from the planet
punkers first showed up in the early
days of Captain Marvel adventures and
half names like Sylvester Herkimer and
jock working alongside mr. mind and his
monster Society of evil much later in
2006 a talking croc named Sobek shows up
and a few weeks later a longtime Shazam
villain Black Adam tears him apart and
makes boots out of his skin so no matter
how you look at it those cardsharp crocs
were actually kind of a big deal and
they'll probably be back for more even
though dr. sivana and mr. mind are some
of Shazam's most memorable foes there's
one that's even more notable black Adam
DC announced Black Adam solo movie in
January of 2017 and it was supposed to
show up before Shazam so what gives the
wizard Shazam mentions in the film that
he had a previous champion who'd
betrayed him and there's little doubt
that he's referring to Black Adam in the
original comic books Black Adam is given
powers of the six ancient gods but uses
some selfishly so the wizard banishes
Black Adam to outer space adam spends
5,000 years trying to make it back to
earth and when he does he jealously
terrorizes billy batson for many more
decades so even though we've set up for
a mr. mind serve on a team up in Shazam
- it's a good bet that the Wizards old
champion will be showing up for a fight
- Shazam has been described as Superman
meets big am a comparison couldn't
possibly be more appropriate especially
after seeing one specific scene in the
movie well Tom Hanks and Robert loggia
may enjoy a charming duet in the middle
of fao schwarz on a king-sized floor
piano and big Shazam gives its own spin
on the scene of drawing a shopping mall
battle between Shazam and Savannah while
they don't quite make the same beautiful
music together the colossal piano they
wind up fighting on drives the
connection home and if you're looking
for truly vintage references look no
further than the iconic cover of 1945
Superman issue 32 where Superman shrugs
off lightning bolts with a casual it
tickles similar words are spoken by
Shazam while bullets bounce off of em
really bringing home that this guy is as
powerful as a Big Blue Boy Scout check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more loop of videos but your
favorite DC movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]